you are watching the press preview first
look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with economist and broadcaster steve
richards and the former
government special adviser sal mushah so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
and according to the financial times the
prime minister is likely to face
opposition from some of his own mps
over the introduction of so-called covid
passports which would allow people
to prove they don't have the virus and
gain entry to public venues
the metro urges readers to book your
table now after boris johnson confirmed
pubs and restaurants
will reopen next week as scheduled
as the express puts it cheers where
opening for business
the guardian says mr johnson has pledged
to return to a semblance of normality
the next stage of the so-called roadmap
is also the top story for the eye
their headline lockdown eases up next
week for pubs
and shops the daily telegraph leads with
that too
but says some covered measures could
remain in place even after all adults
have been offered
a vaccine and that's also
the top story in the daily mail
and uh with us tonight steve richards
and salma shah to take us through the
newspapers good to see you welcome and
let's start with the guardian first of
all and that headline
some semblance of normality um promised
by the prime minister in that briefing
this evening steve you've had a look at
this
yeah well as your introduction to all
the front pages shows
the mood is quite different depending on
what front page you
look at whether it's kind of quite
downbeat or
upbeat and the reason for it is in that
guardian
headline a return to a semblance of
normality what precisely does that
mean the semblance of normality and it's
not entirely
clear in fairness to the government
there's no reason
why it should be entirely clear given
that there are some still
unpredictable factors in this whole saga
but given that uh the front pages really
then differ
some are excited by the return of a
semblance of
normality others think why can't we have
that now given the success
of the vaccines and so within that there
are many questions
vaccine passports yes or no white can't
things open more quickly etc etc and
it all i think does revolve around
the perhaps unavoidable lack of clarity
about what a semblance of normality
means
yes and that that was the the criticism
of that news conference wasn't it selma
that there wasn't enough detail
people still were left with very many
questions even after the briefing
yeah there's still a lot of questions
and there are questions that the
government themselves can't answer at
the moment because you know as the prime
ministers talked about before they're
going to be led by
data not dates and this gradual
unlocking
is going to show um the data that is
coming in
um and show the spread of the virus and
the prime minister also said that we're
expecting to see
a slight spike when we start seeing
hospitality
um starting to open up again i do think
it's interesting you know steve is
absolutely right depending on which
paper you read
um it depends on whether it's going to
be upbeat or downbeat but there are lots
of critical factors here
that the government is still not aware
of which means that this caution is
important
yeah the telegraph slightly different
take normality uh a long
way off no end in sight as johnson says
normal is some
way off uh slightly different take is
matt from from the the guardian
yeah yeah i think carry on
sorry i was i was just going to say it's
a different take from the guardian
because i think also the telegraph
is keen on getting um you know the
economy open up again
opened up again and also it's what does
normality actually mean so
whereas you see with the guardians it's
talking about a semblance um this is
actually challenging
that a little bit more and saying okay
what does normal really look like and
what are we expected to regard as normal
because the briefing today as well was
talking about
um you know the vaccination not being
100 which is what the telegraph
cites in the front page in its copy and
the fact that not everybody is going
to choose to take up a vaccination so
there are still some difficulties
in the road ahead and i think they're
legitimate questions to ask for the
telegraph
of the government and how the government
is going to think about addressing some
of these anomalies
steve you wanted to come in yeah i just
think it's very interesting
the ubiquity of this term normal you
know what
what what is what do people expect by
normal that city centers will be as
packed as they used to be the officers
will be
packed again with people working in them
commuting from all over the place
or will there be some changes which
means normal is different
now we know to some extent what they
mean they want people to be able to go
to restaurants to go to houses
indoors quite quickly but i think the
caution
of the government is wise and is in
marked contrast to some of the things
we've experienced with them
over the last 12 months and to follow
the timetable the reason why some papers
are upbeat
is we knew this was going to happen
being amazing if it hadn't but
you know some things are going to reopen
next
monday isn't it april the 12th yes so
they are following
a timetable i think this kind of focus
on
normal this word is is not very helpful
for
anyone really it is spectacularly
imprecise while appearing to be very
clearly defined
so they're sticking to the timetable but
within that as we've both been
discussing
there are huge questions about the way
forward
after april the 12th yeah so you're
wanting to avoid the word normal but
normally a lot of people would be
booking their summer holidays around
this time if not already booked and that
was something that
we we didn't get any clearer detail on
there was a lot of caution from the
prime minister on whether people should
actually even book summer holidays now
selma
yeah and i think that it too is sensible
because we
are seeing a third wave going across
europe
whose vaccination program has not been
anywhere near as successful as the uk's
so this um uh traffic light system that
has been announced
um i think is going to be you know
there's going to be a long way off
before a lot of countries are in
green um so i think that's all that's
all we had and i think we're going to
have to wait a little bit longer before
we have anything definitive
on what um foreign travel looks like and
also
you know in relation to vaccination
passports
we're also going to have to have those
for international travel
let alone you know the sort of plans of
whether you're going to get one to go to
the pub or not
yeah and it's it's not going to be easy
however we look at it because even with
the traffic light system um steve you
know if you travel to
a green area and spend a couple of weeks
by the time you leave to come back it
could be
a red area yeah i mean
these holidays could be a form of hell
let's be honest
and the other thing here is that uh
quite a lot of the assessment is if
this is wholly in the control of the uh
for england anyway the uh the government
of westminster it's obviously
hugely dependent on what other countries
decide i was we were with some friends
today we saw should we go to
france as if you know the government
here wants us to go
that's fine of course it's up to france
uh or macro or whoever
to decide as well so they're not fully
in control
of traveling abroad this summer they're
obviously going to give more information
in the coming
weeks but their room for maneuver on
this is quite limited
and salmon let's move to the financial
times and they're looking at
the um the backlash from from tory mps
about covid passports i mean there's
quite a split there were 70 mps i think
about 40 of them
tori's who were against the idea of
domestic passports
but it was something that was hinted
quite strongly at in that news briefing
earlier
yeah hinted quite strongly at but not as
strongly as some of the briefing we've
seen
previously which suggests that there
might be
you know a little bit of trepidation um
given that there's going to be some
political difficulties in getting this
through
so the financial times has a report from
mark
harper mp who is leading what is called
the
a covert recovery group saying the
domestic passport or certification
so this is not going to be an easy thing
to get through
parliament because of the civil
liberties issue and it will be
interesting to see
um politically what kia stammer does uh
with the
labour whip and to see whether he
actually does
support the government in introducing
this so
even the best laid plans the best laid
intentions whatever the science says the
politics of this are really going to
matter in the next
few days yeah but the prime minister was
saying that
it's not likely that you would need
certification for essential to get to go
to the shops but perhaps to go to
to a concert or something of that like
steve
yeah i mean he was saying for example
you won't need it to go
to a pub garden next week when the
gardens reopened
but that was never going to that's not
the issue of contention no one expected
that to be the case
it is as you say bigger public events
and possibly going
indoors in pubs restaurants
whether some kind of proof of having the
vaccine
uh is required and i mean i think
there's there are strong arguments
for it but i've got a vote in the house
of commons if there is a vote
and this is very interesting because
stammer has been so criticized for
abstaining
key moments i think he it looks as if
he's veering towards perhaps
deciding to vote against um clearly no
final decision has been made
but actually the abstentions he's done
in the past have actually been quite
constructive that he
criticized some of the specific
proposals but wanted a measure in place
so they abstained
but he's been so knocked about for
abstaining
it could be that the government haven't
got the numbers at the moment with the
tory rebels
and um labor contemplating voting
against assuming there is a vote
okay steve and selma for the moment
thank you very much
coming up one would normally expect the
daily mail to be supportive of tory
policies but not this time when it comes
to easing
lockdown we'll discuss that next please
stay with us
welcome back you're watching the press
preview that's still with me to take us
through the
newspapers this evening steve richards
and salma shah welcome back to you
um let's have a look at the mail a paper
that one might think would
normally support the prime minister um
but
not so salma call this freedom is the
headline
yes and there's a different sort of
flavor amongst all the sort of
writer-leaning uh newspapers so we've
seen the daily mail and the telegraph
already
so different um elements of kind of
concern um i think this is difficult
generally for anybody who is
um pro-business and it slightly worries
about state control
so whilst they understand that there's a
pandemic on i think there's a difficulty
for for everyone on the right uh who are
considering
how much state control somebody should
have a government should have
pitted against the safety of the
population in a pandemic and i think
these are one of the questions that i
think tory backbenchers are also
grappling with at the moment
and steve what's your view well again
it's really interesting the use of terms
call this freedom question mark as if
anyone
is asserting that what we're
experiencing now in the next few weeks
is anything close to freedom but maybe
if this discipline remains in place
there will be a freedom from the virus
which has caused
all the non-freedom for the last year so
again
how you use words in these situations
is very revealing however i think you
know the mail
and the telegraph they they have quite a
lot of influence
on uh governments and on this you know
tory governments
well actually all governments from my
experience um
and they will read this with as much
awareness as they read about
tory mps rebelling against passports so
um they are a factor in determining what
happens in the
coming months but by no means the only
one and as i say i don't quite know what
they mean
by freedom do they want everything back
to normal i've
you know said in the first half it's not
up to the government to decide when
france
opens itself up in terms of holidays etc
etc
freedom is a very vague term which again
sounds strong
some of there have been some suggestions
that perhaps we should be looking
at our borders uh especially in the
light of this this third wave
um and we should be closing our borders
in order to
protect our citizens from being infected
yes and i think in this instance you
have to really consider
what the scientists are saying about how
things travel
and i would personally be
very afraid of um border controls
being so um hard but
these the vaccination needs to be
protected and the more mutations you
have and the more things travel
the riskier um that vaccination is in
this
in this um tranche so we already know
that what spread in europe the first
time was not
exactly the same as what came out of
china because it went through several
different mutations
so the border question is a really
tricky one because there is actual
science that says we have to reduce the
risk of mutations
but you know closing down the border
that is a that is a really tough thing
to do
steve do you think that that might be
something that will be looked at if if
other countries are having rates of the
infection rising
and we're actually doing quite well with
our vaccination program being so
successful
and our rate being reduced might that be
an area that will be one of
concentration on
yeah well it already is um and
that there has been a considerable
tightening of the borders
compared if you take a year ago there
was still a sort of free-for-all at uk
borders it was one of the reasons why
there was such a heavy infection rate in
the uk
from about a year ago i mean
to be honest i think the question should
be are they tight enough
now given uh what we know about the
potential impact
of variance and still not complete
clarity
about whether the vaccines protect
everyone from all
variants so there needs to be real
caution and of course i understand the
impatience as reflected in
uh the mail and the telegraph but if
this goes
wrong uh look at what's happening in
europe if this goes wrong
we're going to lose all the freedoms
again so it has got to be done i think
very cautiously uh salmon just time for
this uh story the the metro uh take us
into the story about uh david cameron
yes so this is uh obviously a
continuation
of uh the issues that is being looked at
around
lobbying and again uh rachel reeves i
believe the labour mp
is uh suggesting that there needs to be
uh some legislation
cut brought forward in the queen's
speech with relation to lobbying
the thing about this is is that it's one
of those perennial issues where
anybody who sort of leaves a political
um
political career and then goes off and
pursues their own
uh job are always going to be sort of
somehow pulled back
into talking to their old contact so
whilst i think it's laudable
to say that we need better protections
against um
lobbying i just don't know how you
practically build bring legislation
forward
to prevent people from talking to the
treasury
in this case about things that are
materially significant
to jobs and the economy